there's a misconception i think with a
lot of filmmakers where they think i'm
gonna do this great movie and it's just
gonna speak for itself
and i'm not saying that that never
happens still i'm sure it does but for
the most part
we have to get out there and become the
face of it or somebody does like we have
to sell it
why is it hard to make money as a
filmmaker
so
today i think
today i think the easy answer to why
it's hard to make money off movies is
there's just so many of them i mean on
one hand you know i love
the democratization of filmmaking you
know the way you know gear has gotten
affordable you know cameras are more and
more affordable i mean look at the
blackmagic 6k i mean you can get that
now for what like uh like 2500 for the
body and i mean that kind of technology
would have cost
90 grand 10 years ago you know or 60 or
something like that it was crazy
and and and that is awesome and there's
all these people like you know we had
the you were reading the comment earlier
and they're talking about how they made
a movie in 97 and they had to spend 50
000 to make that movie i guarantee you
you could make that exact same thing
today not on 16 for
15 000 guarantee it you know i mean well
yeah almost
and uh
you know i think that that is super
exciting and cool but on the other hand
because everybody can make movies
everybody's making movies and
they're so it's so hard to get
attention it's so hard to get eyeballs
on your individual project because
there's just so much more of it and then
you know and again because there's so
much more of it so many more places to
put it the value of those individual
projects is less now and i think that is
the main reason that it's harder today
to make money on films than it was 10
years ago
what do most independent filmmakers get
wrong about making money from their
independent films
um i sound like a broken record with it
but i think the number one thing
filmmakers get wrong is they don't think
about the business i i you know and i'm
not saying it has to be like all
business and business first and then
creative no you like it your movie has
to be good the creativity has to work
that's a given so like i i got some
pushback on my channel early on because
i was talking all about distribution and
marketing they're like well well what if
the movies just not need good you know
the movie has to be good i'm like well
yeah that's that's a given your movie
has to be good that's
like duh
but
what people don't put any focus on or
don't want to they don't want to think
about the business
you know and again because so many more
people are doing it
you have to be better and better at
getting eyeballs on that project like
you have to be able to
market yourself and not and not just
your movie you have to be able to market
yourself
like there's a
there's a misconception i think with a
lot of filmmakers where they think i'm
going to do this great movie and it's
just going to speak for itself
and i'm not saying that that never
happens still i'm sure it does
but for the most part
we have to get out there and become the
face of it or somebody does like we have
to sell it you know and we have to sell
ourselves
you know like now it's not enough to be
an independent filmmaker
make a couple of movies and just you
know
coast off of that let let the movies
bring in all your income
you have to get out there and you have
to you have to become uh man i i hate
even saying this but you have to become
a brand
you know like that's where it is and and
if if that all sounds like disgusting to
you an icky yuck
second you need to second think being a
being a
filmmaker a professional filmmaker today
and when i say professional filmmaker
again i'm talking about filmmakers that
are making money off the exhibition of
their films i'm not talking about dps
they're getting hired to do stuff i'm
not talking about gaffers that are hired
to do stuff i'm not talking about four
paid directors i'm talking about people
that are you're gonna go out there and
you're gonna
put the movie together as an
entrepreneur and make money off of it
what if someone says though because
we've been talking about you know kevin
smith spike lee uh richard linklater um
and robert rodriguez quentin tarantino
what if those are some interesting
people they're just interesting to
listen to yeah yeah you know you just
put them at a podium
i heard kevin smith speak at a
conference and and he's just fascinating
so but not everybody's like that yeah
that's true
um
so i i think it's a matter of like
leaning in to your strengths you know
like like like me for example i like i
am not as charismatic as say like kevin
smith or quentin tarantino and like i'm
not as knowledgeable about film is
quentin tarantino you know and honestly
like like i sound like i'm pretty good
on camera now but i've been i've been
practicing this on my youtube channel
now for three years you know so like i
i'm
decent now but i had to work at it i
mean at the very beginning i was very uh
uh
didn't know where to look didn't know
what to do with my hands am i gonna talk
am i talking with my hands too much like
i i was i was and the whole time you
know that imposter syndrome kicks in and
you're like
nobody cares what i have to say like i'm
talking about making 50 000 movies and
making a modest living on it who cares
about that we all want to be rock stars
we don't want to make a million dollars
nobody's gonna listen to this
and but i just i just kept at it and
building it and then over time you know
it built up a little bit and people
started responding to it and it's it's
helped feed all of my other work and all
of the effort that i put into getting
better on camera and stuff like that you
know i just did a crowdfunder and i did
a pitch video and you know no no ego i
think i did a really good pitch video
and 90 of that is me being able to
present on camera better because i've
i've practiced it for three years
you know and just as a quick side note
the amount raised was oh we raised uh
57 000 now congratulations thank you
that's great yeah indiegogo yes
excellent yeah excellent what was the
biggest mistake you made in attempting
to make money from your films or was
that the biggest mistake
that that was your end goal
and that shouldn't have been and
therefore that was the mistake
my biggest mistake making i keep
repeating the questions
my biggest mistake uh
in
not making money on early films was
looking at it waiting for someone else
to
to do it
for me whether and this isn't an
anti-distributor tirade or anything
because i i distributors have their
place i like them i still use
distributors but
there's this thing with like new
filmmakers where we just want to make
our movie and give it over to something
and then that thing is going to bring
our money in and we don't have to worry
about it somebody else's problem it's
somebody else's
job to market it it's somebody else's
job to distribute it it's somebody
else's job to think about the audience
you know and
it's in
if you're making a movie at a certain
level it can be but if you are making
fifty thousand dollar movies or twenty
thousand dollar movies you don't have
what money in the budget to hire those
people so you have to do it
when
eventually i came to the realization
that like
i just have to do all these things i
have to learn it and i have to do it and
once i came to that realization and
started working towards it it's like
it's like the world stopped fighting me
you know if like before it was just like
everything was fighting me i would you
know i was like i i need to go with this
distributor because like they do
marketing and they're gonna do this this
and that and
it didn't work out and then you know i
did another one and it didn't work out
and i'm like
what am i doing wrong i'm i'm counting
too much on others to make my
dreams come true you know at a certain
point and i'm not saying
to not collaborate or not to ask for
help or not to seek out you know other
people to help facilitate your success
but
at the end of the day it's like
you have
we have to do it for ourselves
do you think that and i'm going to sound
a little classist here but it comes
under the uh diy sort of punk ethos or
or working class filmmaker
whereas someone else and again people
are going to come at me for this but i
don't want to get my hands dirty i don't
do that
someone else can do that for me yes i
think i think that's absolutely an
element of it and and i don't think it's
always a
like you know like the like a classist
like oh i just like i'm too good for
that i think a lot of people are really
scared of it
like i like when it comes to marketing
or like brand building i think most
filmmakers are scared of it like and and
then they'll
they'll
they'll twist that into you know like
i'm too good for it or you know or into
anger or i shouldn't have to do that you
know and they'll get mad but you know i
i i think a lot of like you know bad
behavior like in filmmaking comes from
anxiety and being scared and and it's
scary it's a scary thing you know i i
suffer from pretty extreme social
anxieties and i like every single movie
i'm i'm an anxious wreck
you know but
i
i get i get through it
but then on camera you
ease through it and and you're
interesting to listen to and you have
great tips yeah you know it's it's so
it's so weird like i i was a uh so i've
always been a super anxious person but
like i've also always had like a
performance bug you know like i you know
really early on i wanted to be an actor
a singer i i was in a rock band right
out of high school like i could i could
get up right now and you know go to a
karaoke karaoke bar and like like tear
up some karaoke right and wouldn't be
nervous at all but you know say like i
had to go do
like a like a like a one-on-one
um
like like ted talk or something like
that where i'm
that and i and i couldn't like write it
out or have it you know like on
teleprompter or something that would
freak me out
you know or like i have trouble
as a producer it's a really it's a
problem for me as a producer i have
trouble like like calling people
like you know like like reaching out
like i'm looking for a location so this
person owns a location i have trouble
making that call
you know i do it but i have but i have
problems with it but i can go on camera
and blah blah blah blah blah
but then i get nervous doing live
streams you know like i get really
nervous doing live streams